é eu vou contar basicamente a minha
história
uma das minhas histórias né e bom
ela começa pelo fato de eu ser surfista
penso que há quase 40 anos falei prancha
há 30 anos e em 96
aconteceu uma situação que mudou a minha
vida radicalmente então foi a partir daí
que eu deixei uma pessoa que me tornei
outra pessoa
e foi assim foi a partir do momento que
alguns amigos no equador é que eu já vi
a de 94
o chileno daqueles botas prancha debaixo
do braço e sai por aí eu já tinha essa
cultura tal de viajar e alguns amigos
equatorianos estava na minha casa e
estavam voltando do equador que tinha
acabado uma greve de lá e tinha começado
uma greve é justo não funciona hoje
então aproveitei bom viajar e voltar
para o equador que vocês falam depois
vão pegar um assunto e assim na minha
vida até então
então nessa época 9896 estava
acontecendo uma uma guerra entre equador
e peru por causa do norte do do peru
tudo e 14 era muito rico em petróleo
então estavam a mulher não estava bem
complicada aquela divisa com atravessar
tv integração tal era bem complicado a
gente tentou comprar a passagem da
cidade e ele uma praga é filme não
conseguiu
então a gente
o avião e até tumbes que era 30
quilômetros da fronteira e daí pegar uma
outra função e tocar pro lá pra
guayaquil bom chegar nos incumbe sair
tinha uma família de colombianos sua
classe filhas mas juntos pegamos um táxi
né eu taxista até falou pra gente olha a
planejada uma fila enorme por causa da
do controle à ahmad virgem
eu tenho uma sugestão de a gente pegar
uma outra outra rota passar por dentro
do coelho que é justamente uma
massagista é um povoado que a gente
precisa fingir que era um dia seco
naquela época a fim de anos atrás é é um
apelo que o equador
eles eram muito parecidos um filme do
méxico mex e quinta categoria
era uma coisa a gente chamava de restos
do nada ela realmente horrível 11 é
muito pior que qualquer situação no
nordeste do brasil
então nós chegamos lá ela é o resultado
desse top 50 teuni do coelho vencedor em
manter o nível 1 chego lá aquelas casas
caindo aos pedaços assim eram feitas com
o que tinha é disponível e chegou ao
ponto de tia talvez só esse o século e
ele é usado como lixão basicamente ele
inclusive criar um coffee galinha um
cachorro estava tudo junto
rita tira aquela indicia que os
cachorros box e galinhas eu fui uma
criança de 5 anos de idade processo não
era mais difícil e já o chocante ver uma
criança no meio da tela e um disse
e aí eu até tenho aplicado no amigo
equatoriano estava na frente do carro
unitau assim olha digital e os
colombianos a família traz também e essa
criança pra minha surpresa ela achou ele
tem um filho tem um negócio ou tornar o
que comeu
foi a primeira vez que eu vi uma criança
uma pessoa como lixo até então nunca
tinha visto aquilo ali ter foi como um
conhecido de mula do meu inconsciente
eu tive uma crise e não não sabia mais o
que muitas coisas que eu pensava se foi
eu sou um cara que estou aqui incluindo
já o sofá
o meu mundo é maravilhoso está
entendendo e eu não levei um choque de
realidade daquelas pessoas que têm um
mundo rico e aquilo foi transformador
para mim que as próprias pessoas que
estavam ali no carro tirando o taxista
que pra ele e ela normal mas nós ficamos
chocados e aquele momento eu não
conseguir mais e ver direito com aquela
situação
aquilo foi tão traumático que a quadra
todo momento eu fui aquela criança um
rosto aquela louca teta de sujeira
provavelmente ela vivia no meio da
galera onde não se tinha família ou não
mas aquino entrou no meu visk marcou
profundamente da lei a gente seguiu
viagem
eu fui pro braga lavra o fogo queima 51
negócio sinistra eu
tem pra florianópolis e nessa época eu
estava ajudando na eth um vazio porque
ele estava sendo é construído lá eo eu
estava ajudando na a amarrar a
valorização principalmente com chutes
euros que o que acontecia minha família
e meus pais são da roça e a gente
recupera de fazer compostagem do lixo de
um subproduto da compostagem a produção
de mudas
daí quem faz a compostagem sabe o que
acontece
as mudas e não simplesmente não jogava
fora pegava fazer voltar os saquinhos
tal e no caso eu estava plantando lá no
bairro coqueiros e aí deu aquele estalo
na minha cabeça como eu era criança eu
saía depois da escola e ia para a rua
naquela época 48 anos atrás a gente
vivia na rua depois da escola todo mundo
não pode uma fome ou ian no sítio de
alguém subir em água e comia o que tinha
lá tinha muitas árvores que será um
pouquinho da minha infância ea gente não
pensava em voltar para casa para fazer
um lanche e depois de brincar
pegava a subir numa árvore economia
então tenho que ele falou pô lo acabando
a aaa o plantio aqui no parque não tem
mais fácil o que eu não sigo um
pouquinho mais
o plantão até onde dá dali seguir até a
confluência da ponte
o expresso
em florianópolis mas tem uma via
expressa chega nas contas e dali eu
comecei a plantar nas marginais fazer
plantios 550 60 muitos tal e fui até
chegar uma região mais tarde seria
naquela época era o bairro de capoeira é
uma falácia que recém tinha sido
organizada por que ser uma favela ele eo
pessoal entorno
quando cheguei pra plantar em só por
favor planta longa que se não precisou
da favela têm invadindo de novo e tal
então eles até ajudaram sentiu um certo
interesse deles mas não na em
transformar aquela área numa área é
autorizado ou se eles queriam que fosse
poupado para evitar que a favela com
fácil mas se eles ajudaram ela pessoas
mais velhas e tal e dali
teve um senhor que foi ajuda virou foi
um tremendo replicador do projeto
modificado e aí depois ele continuou o
plantio também e eu daria se seguindo no
sentido da br 101
aí eu cheguei numa outra comunidade que
aí no caso muito mais batizada que é a
favela chico mendes hoje já não se chama
mais favela é bairro chico mendes
enfim eu até fiquei com bastante medo
ali onde estacionar o carro com que eu
ia chegar ali como ia ser recebido pôde
ser assaltado
coisas assim mais pra minha felicidade
eu cheguei naquela comunidade foi muito
recebido as pessoas curiosas também
alguém que está fazendo nenhuma escuta
saque e tal aí tô aqui nesse canteiro
não tem árvore nenhuma eu vou plantar
umas árvores a equipe até uma ajuda e
foi uma situação que o via se eu cheguei
todo preconceituoso e foi recebido com
uma maneira que eu fiquei muito surpresa
e ali naquela ocasião eu conheci uma
moça se chama margarida e ela ficou uma
retificadora importantíssima naquela
comunidade até então ela não era nem
conhecida e hoje ela se tornou uma líder
comunitária ela faz a partir daquele
momento ela ajudou no plantio das
notícias de ir passou a produzir uma
horta e plantas medicinais e hoje é uma
referência para quem tinha alguma doença
chega na comunidade
ao que eu tenho uma dor aqui uma viagem
até aquilo que eu posso tá ela vai lá e
corda pra ele
enfim é esses indicadores
eles só se formam
só aparecem quando aparece alguém pra
dar um evento para mostrar uma situação
muito simples que pode fazer mas tem que
aparecer só pessoa e essa pessoa pode
ser qualquer um de nós como foi o meu
caso eu jamais imaginei que eu fosse
aparecer no próprio programa da globo
que hoje eu pudesse estar aqui em lages
um tele falando pra várias pessoas
e são situações que às vezes a pessoa
precisa do estágio como foi aquele
menino pra mim que me transformou em uma
pessoa acomodada em uma situação de
conforto total que viu o mundo com 11 um
olhar ea partir daquele momento se
transformou em outra pessoa olhando
mundo com outro olhar
hoje eu me dedico a há a questão da
solidariedade humana e enxergar o outro
em colocar no lugar do outro a partir do
momento em que aquela criança apareceu
na minha filha ela foi como um sopro de
deus assim pra mim chega ele chove neste
sentido na vida mas o teu sentido esse e
pra mim foi excepcional aquele momento
a partir dali a não não sei se aquela
criança não sei nem que sim deus ela
hoje está viva se ela serviço ou não mas
eu sei que a partir daquele momento eu
passei agir e ter ela como uma
referência
eu eu passei a ser importante para
outras pessoas e começou o meu bairro
passou por uma área maior e hoje o
trabalho é fortemente para transformar o
plantio de frutíferas em áreas carentes
de uma política pública e hoje depois de
20 anos que eu estou conseguindo seu
filho pela pelo poder público têm
secretários estão me chamando pra eu
expliquei antes
isso a dez anos atrás eu procurava a
eles e eles ficam só com os olhos a
todos os intensivos que podia acontecer
com o plantio de frutíferas tela é é uma
espécie de frutas caídas no chão
adolescente trazendo mostra trazendo
rato folhas caindo e aumentar o custo e
tal eu tentava explicar que aquilo dali
era justo que a gente procurava por dia
os juros podem ser usado pra abrange 12
e sucos de polpa e colégio chup chup
várias coisas que podem gerar ainda há o
corte das árvores pode vender lenha pra
pizzarias das baías
as folhas podem ser usada pra pra
atender plataforma de chá
enfim mais eles não conseguirão se
colocar no lugar das outras pessoas
isso falta é a coisa que talvez só
demais no nosso planeta essa capacidade
da pessoa se colocar no lugar do outro
é isso que gera o espírito de
solidariedade não só com sexualidade
consegue se colocar no lugar da outra
pessoa
se não não para uma faixa de trânsito
uma pessoa passava entre né senão tu não
abre a porta para uma pessoa que tinha
uma deficiência física
isso simplesmente só vai ter um espírito
solidário se conseguisse colocar no
lugar do professor é fundamental e é uma
coisa que a gente entenda que nós temos
um obrigação moral com o
o movimento do da civilização humana a
barriga do momento que a gente
disseminar esse conhecimento também
muitas vezes a pessoa passa a vida toda
a senha de que essa capacidade e outras
pessoas eu tive a graça de deus me dá
essa é essa
esse episódio traumático e eu consegui
me colocar o primeiro lugar da criança é
uma situação e desesperador
e hoje eu vejo as todas as crianças
mesmo aquelas tem comida de uma
comunidade carente
mas como se fosse aquela criança porque
nada impede que ela um determinado
momento aconteça alguma é algum acidente
de geográfico algum problema a climático
que foge à disposição na disponibilidade
de alimento e se a gente usasse como uma
estratégia pra da segurança alimentar
das cidades para as comunidades
isso ia ser fundamental e tirar a gente
tem uma situação de risco também é eu
queria muito que tivesse aqui não se tem
políticas aqui tem algum político aqui
o vereador infelizmente não é muito da
eu já esperava encerramento
é a já é difícil a gente ia atrás dele
eles houve muito menos eles aparecerem
aqui proteger mas então se a gente
entender e exclusivamente dos políticos
vocês sabem que a situação não anda
então há como vários réus já tocado
nesse assunto para a gente melhorar a
nossa sociedade para a gente melhorar o
nosso planeta
a gente não pode delegar essa função ao
super bem
nenhum outro entendendo porque isso é
tentar delegando a responsabilidade amor
depende de nós pra gente melhorar nossas
uma sociedade que cada um de nós tem se
procura melhorar a cabeleira é sócio
se eu sou uma pessoa eu tenho que
melhorar meu amigo tem que servir
melhorar e assim sucessivamente
a gente pode chegar só assim vai ser
possível a gente tem uma civilização em
uma sociedade onde as pessoas consigam
se colocar no lugar do outro sofrer no
lugar do outro e é isso que falta também
da nossa classe política
infelizmente mas hoje a gente trabalha
muito e eu como ambientalista também pra
gente conseguir conscientizar as pessoas
que político não é todo igual quem
infelizmente inicial muito poucos mas
nenhum outro da nossa sociedade se
propõe entrar nesse meio extremamente
tóxico cuidadoso mas ele está se
dedicando a entrar lá e lutar por causas
genéticas para a sociedade
a gente tem que se dá a esse trabalho de
pesquisar quem são realmente pessoas que
vale a pena votar votar nessas pessoas
as outras eleições ajudar votar mais 23
e que tirando toda uma coxa que tem lá
que integre a nossa sociedade de se
desenvolver
e olha isso muito técnico que te dá a
oportunidade de vir aqui eu não tenho
nada em uma imagem pra mostrar não ser a
minha própria linha não é eu eu até
pessoalmente sou muito mais fique aí na
foto mas a vida é assim mas a gente pode
se tornar muito mais bonito
agora depois de falar e as pessoas até
me vinha por cada filho mas até podia
fazer o que nós podemos e diógenes é
muito fácil a gente significa o número
que eu prego o espírito de solidariedade
não custa nada tinha
o menino se pode fazer é plantar uma
valeu desligado